on the next Rick and Morty Rick and
Morty next Sunday night at 11:30 only on
Adult Swim hey everybody knew Rick and
Morty's so new conspiracy theory there's
a lot of talk that's happening about
Episode seven in some conflicting
evidence the creators have come out and
talked that makes it sound like it's
going to be their version of a season
three interdimensional cable episode
without actually being interdimensional
cable three so it's actually supposed to
be really cool despite the pitch being
deceptively simple up until recently
most sites were crediting the title of
the episode as tales from the Citadel
without an actual description but now
the title is being listed as the Rick
lantus mix-up in the description reads
Atlantis were coming a nice little
self-contained episode about Atlantis is
waiting for the audience which basically
sounds like nothing like oh we're just
gonna go to Atlantis it's gonna be a
nice little one-off adventure it won't
be a serialized with the divorce and all
that other stuff in that's in so because
Rick and Morty is just laden with so
much sarcasm and the way they pitch
stuff it just sounds like that's meant
to be completely misleading and it's
going to be some much bigger idea even
if it isn't connected to the divorce and
the ongoing storyline so that's where it
sounds like they might be working in
vignettes with a bunch of
interdimensional cable type stories
without it actually being that that
might be an opportunity for some of
these scenes from the opening credits
like with all the crazy different
versions of Morty at boarding school
the whole thing with interdimensional
cable is they said that they would be
doing something like that every year but
just after I posted my episode 7 trailer
video a couple days ago Ryan ridley
confirmed that they wouldn't be doing
interdimensional cable 3 but to expect
another fun treat which sounds like
they're gonna be doing a version of that
without doing the exact same thing
because it does sound like they tire of
doing the exact same stick over and over
which is why you haven't seen the
meeseeks come back all the time why you
haven't seen mr. poopy butthole right
away there's this quote that Justin
roiland gave a long time ago where he
talks about them doing their own version
of Simpsons Treehouse of horrors where
they do something every year like that
but it's a little bit different so
there's his Comic Con clip where he
talks a little bit of
that but it's where he's talking about
the follow-up to rixty minutes if there
was gonna be another episode like rixty
minutes because i love that episode so
much and just the randomness and the
improvisation was pretty freakin awesome
can we just say that that's ER oh yeah
we are gonna do another one of those
yeah that's yeah that's gonna be our
treehouse of horror
I mean we're gonna do one of those every
season so yes yeah there's there there's
another episode of rixty minik minutes
it's got a different title but uh but
yeah we're really we and we like these
guys just because up till 4:00 a.m.
you're up to 5 a.m. 5 a.m. writing the B
story for it just like last week so
which I think we have to throw out well
I mean we get excited I'm excited it's a
Jerry story it's really good so
obviously when he said that that episode
would have a different title he's
talking about interdimensional cable -
that's the episode where Jerry got in
trouble had to go to the alien hospital
and then they did all those news stories
[Music]
where there's eight Qin Michael Vincent
and sixteen quadrants there's only
enough time for a Jan Michael Vincent to
make it to a quadrant he can't be at two
quadrants at once so there's still a
couple scenes in the opening credits
that they could include if they're going
to be doing separate vignettes whether
or not we're following around the same
version of Rick and Morty the entire
time we have the but world we have
Terminator summer we have boarding
school Morty with all the different
versions of Morty and then we have the
morty store so let me know in the
comments if they were billing the
episode as tales from The Citadel in
Ryan really confirmed that they would
have a fun spin on interdimensional
cable coming up then do you think that's
what episode 7 is supposed to be there's
actually another fun theory that I've
seen start to pop up because they're
going to Atlantis in the teaser people
are now theorizing that Rick is the
person who sank Atlantis but the only
problem with that is that as far as we
know he doesn't travel in time he may
have done it in the past because he has
a box of time-travel stuff so at some
point he did time travel time travel is
a real shark jumper yes if you once you
introduce into the Canon of your show
the idea it's just a dangerous toy to
pull out and by the way Rick never
traveled that none of them traveled yeah
it was pause time right fractures time
so they're in a space where they have
become theoretical instead of real yeah
although your key night viewer will
notice that Rick and is garage is a box
that's labeled yeah because that's some
[ __ ] he's been trying to work that's the
joke is that it's on the show much like
your scripted Fox you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] piece of genui rescind it's
possible that he could have sunk
Atlantis but without more evidence or
more footage and without Rick just
outright saying that he time traveled
and accidentally did something to
Atlantis there's no way to confirm that
but what's gonna happen is is because
there's no new episode on Sunday there's
a new Morty video that I'm working on as
well as a gravity falls Easter Egg
montage so those will post in the next
week or so but just leave all your Rick
and Morty video requests in the comments
below
they've been a little radio silent
recently aside from Dan Harmon speaking
up about the big game of thrones dick
just saying how it was kind of crass and
they had nothing to do with it
regardless of where you followed that
spectrum but there is a new round of
that Zen monkey Studios merch giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video cake man
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for brand new Rick
and Morty and you can click here for
brand new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]